I'm gonna be honest with you tonight I
could have watched a girl than the
spider's web but Nazi zombies man nazi
zombies kind of Overlord overlords one
of those movies I don't know how many
people are gonna go to this over the
weekend so plot as I thought it was
because that's what the trailer show
world war two these American soldiers
they parachute to France they have a job
to do but they find out the Nazis are
creating zombies so now they gotta take
down zombies it's a zombie apocalypse
movie with nazi zombies the premise is
actually a lot of that but it's just
there's not a zombie apocalypse it's
more or less we got to blow up that lab
before the apocalypse happens and that
zombie threats how many there are two
zombies actually technically three
pethor two but doesn't mean the movies
lame this movie actually hooked me early
on it was just playing crash scene you
see it in the trailer it's actually
really intense between that the set
pieces the gunfights when they happen
that is when they're not hanging out in
the house talking actually really
impressive this is a movie that wants to
dip one toe maybe one foot in the gravy
element it doesn't fully want to commit
to being a great b-movie not like Planet
Terror like Planet Terror was like yeah
this is what we are we are supposed to
be a grind house gravy flick that's why
it's fun this movie takes itself a bit
more seriously than that it's as serious
as a movie about Nazis they're making
zombies possibly can and the cash did a
really fine job funny enough the
Corporal who's the leader because he's
the highest-ranking one the
highest-ranking surviving person he's
the hardcore Duty's can get the job done
but sometimes you close your eyes when
he's talking and you swear you were
hearing Nicolas Cage talk not all the
time but sometimes he sounds like
Nicolas Cage so you got the hardcore guy
you got the dude that makes all the
snarky remarks he's kind of a dick and
you got our good paragon hero ty
crandall movie that's pretty violent
like unsettlingly violent sometimes I
guess it's a positive of this movie
having one foot in the grade beat
element the other foot in the grade a
element in a great b-movie for me if
someone gets plugged in the head I'm
like yeah it's a great B movie you know
Gore when a movie starting to take
itself a bit seriously and then you see
it happier like huh this movie has that
going for it and when one of the two
zombie situations is actually happening
and this thing is chasing this girl's
actually it's pretty intense I do feel
like this movie could have picked up the
pace at a point maybe they could have
used more zombies at this point maybe
they could have brought the zombies out
earlier and they had more to deal with
by the end hanging out in this house and
it has its own thing going on I'm just
saying after the insane parachute crash
landing secrets at the beginning then
alright we got to go to the mission to
get the job done in between there is a
bit of a lull I suppose I'm telling you
I'm in
arming you that there are not a lot of
zombies in this movie to essentially
brace you for that I want you going into
this movie thinking if some sort of
zombie horror movie set yourself up for
that you're gonna set yourself up for
disappointment snot really what it's
about you go into this movie with the
mindset that this is a world war two
movie about American soldiers who have a
job to do they have to blow up this
antenna and beat the living piss out of
an SS officer it's always a fun Saturday
and side note there's a secret lab where
Nazis you're making zombies I gotta deal
with that too I think he'll have a
pretty fun time with those mom you're
sayin Overlord was a pretty good time to
lock the heart required this movie
treats itself as a war movie first it's
actually more intense than a lot of war
movies I've seen lately actually feels
more real and more legit than a lot of
war movies I've seen like look at again
there haven't been a lot of war movies
instead of saying lately I'm just saying
the execution of the war element at
impressment right so overlord have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite war movie or zombie
movie lately whatever that whatever do
you think I meant below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]